[Music]
let's go to Justine in Providence Road
Island hey Justine what's happening hi
Dr Delani how are you good how are you
oh I'm hanging in hanging in all right
what's up you could complain then you
sound like one of our politicians what's
up um yeah so I guess my my main
question is how do I mourn my mother who
is still very much alive and um how do I
second question is how do I get my heart
to agree with my brain in that it's time
to end that
relationship what what has happened that
brought you here that's one of the most
sacred relationships a mother and her
daughter what happened yeah and I'm I'm
going to try to get to this about
getting emotional but hey get as
emotional as you can I mean that's this
this is few things are more emotional
Than This Moment is having a funeral for
somebody that's still alive yeah it's
it's been awful um so I guess long story
short my mom is
um she has has battled a prescription um
pill addiction for about 13 14 years man
what that's the devil dude it's the
devil it's it's awful and on top of that
she is borderline personality disorder
sh and so um you know she had me very
young I had very tumultuous childhood
I've um finally kind of come to a place
in my life I'm 34 now uh where I am
married to a wonderful man I have a
stable home we just had our first child
five months ago um congrats how's that
going thank you oh he's he's just
amazing he's wonderful I know he
probably is how are
you I'm you know I'm doing really well
with all of that but the the problem is
that I had
even though I she's been crazy for my
whole life and then when the pill
started it was like a whole different
kind of crazy I still somehow had this
idea in my head that if I was able to
make my life as perfect as possible and
um you know have give her the beautiful
grandchild and and do all these things
that she would see that and want to be
well so that she could be a part of it
and even though I knew that wasn't
reality I there was still a part of me
that was like well you know just keep
doing this and that and and here I am
you know
thinking well maybe my mom will show up
for me and she just she just hasn't and
now that I'm a mother myself
I'm I just it's different now because
you know she has been violent and the
cops get involved every other week and
the drugs back and forth and I I can't
have my kid around that I I can't have
my kid exposed to those things and now
I'm just Justine Justine this has never
been your job and I'm so sorry it has
been for 34 years yeah it's been awful
like I've had to have her um committed
on a 5150 before flown across the
country to put her under
rehab um but listen this has never been
your
fault I know you know that
intellectually I'm trying to say it to
where your heart can hear it right and
that's the problem it was your
job and now let me tell me if I'm wrong
you're holding this beautiful
five-year-old five-month-old
baby and it becomes real in a different
way it's very intellectual when you're a
kid and your mom and you're trying to
survive and you know how to talk to your
mom and deescalate her and things like I
don't want her to go to jail and I don't
want her to die like those are all
intellectual Pursuits they're very very
real and
tangible but then when you hold your
baby it's like how in the
hell could you choose all that over this
right yes absolutely it almost makes you
insane because that math just simply
doesn't compute yes and then you go from
oh my gosh I've been keeping you Al for
29 years or 30 years or 33 years or 34
years to rage Fair yeah
yes yeah how dare you when you see how
innocent and beautiful and wonderful
this is right how dare you yes and
so I mean the hardest question is how I
mean when are you going to let
go here's what you're doing I'm gonna
give you a crass example you keep
showing up at your local Burger King
walking in and making burgers
and they're like you don't work here and
you're like nah I'm great at this I can
make good Whoppers yeah and then you go
work to register and they're like you
literally don't work here you're like
yeah I'm good at this though and you are
pretty good at
it and every time you leave they're like
I mean I'll take the free labor but she
doesn't even work here it's not her job
yep so when yeah you talked about you
talk your baby doesn't deserve to be
around this you don't want your husband
around this
crap when are you going to start caring
about
Justine well and that's that's the thing
is that you know my my head tells me
that my head's like you don't deserve
this you know she has through her
behavior has opted out of relationship
with me she doesn't want to be well and
you know that's her saying I don't care
I want to live my life and be a lunatic
and that's just what it's going to be
but my heart is saying well it's the
only mother you've got well one day
she's not going to be here and you're
going to be sorry you couldn't just put
up with it you know and like I I'm gonna
tell you something
awful can I tell you an awful truth yes
you can when she's gone you will feel a
relief and a peace that you did not know
existed I I already yeah I understand
that you will beat yourself up for the
next decade out of guilt for feeling
that way
yeah you will exhale in a way that you
did not know was
possible and then you'll feel so bad for
doing it
yep I I've anticipated
that yeah it's just awful it is I mean
I've cut all Communications with her and
you know it's holidays and it's
especially hard around the holidays just
not not having your mom not having your
your kids spend their first Christmas
with their their grandmother and and
it's her that left you right okay and I
have a special special place in my soul
for people who struggle with addiction
I've walked with them I've sat with them
I have it and most of my career has been
spent picking up relational
shrapnel from the path of Destruction
people struggling with addiction leave
on their loved ones their kids their
spouses right so I have a deep
compassion and I also have a reality
okay one of the hardest things in the
world to do I think is to watch a loved
one who's an adult make choices that
will destroy them and you they do not
want your support or help or
input that's correct it's devastating
it's a slow motion train wreck that
you're watching and you here's what
makes it worse you you you could stop
it sort
of
as your uh nonsensical um control over
every variable of the world lies to you
and tells you you can you can't stop it
Justin you can't you can't what you can
do is get yourself stuck between that
brick wall that's coming and the train
and get yourself killed
too you can destroy your
marriage you can put your kid in
situations that makes your kid
incredibly unsafe right right yeah and
not that I can't allow either of those
things that's right so here's I'm gonna
give you the advice I given a thousand
times on this
show and um I'm going to add one caveat
to it and it's going to require some
homework from you okay okay are you
willing to try absolutely and listen if
this tanks if this does not work I want
you to call me back I've never had
somebody say it doesn't work but I'm
sure they've tried it and it hasn't but
every single person who's done this has
said I hate the fact that this worked as
as U effectively as it did okay it's
going to take three weeks start now and
um we're recording this show about 3
weeks four weeks outside of Christmas if
you start right now you can land this
plane right on Christmas
Day
cool it will not feel good all right
okay I want you number one to set a
timer for 20 to 30 minutes you get to
pick and I want you to write a letter to
your
mother about all the amazing things she
she gave you she brought
you and it could be backhanded
compliments like I'm so strong because I
had to learn how to navigate the mental
health system and I had to learn how to
do impatient paperwork for my mom when I
was
12 it made you made me you taught me
what love looks like because you kept
coming back even though you were stoned
out of your mind or you wouldn't take
your meds right like I want you to write
a love letter to your mom saying thank
you okay that's week one I want you to
write that on a Monday and I want you to
read that letter every day the rest of
the
week okay yep second week I want you to
write a
letter uh that starts to your mom how
dare
you and this one might be more than 30
minutes but this is where the anger and
the frustration and the rage and the
Heartbreak come out on
paper yeah remember that time you left
me when I was seven remember that time
you three men spending the night in our
house and fill in the
blank yeah you shouldn't have done that
to a little girl you shouldn't have you
see what I'm saying I want I want you to
write that
letter okay okay yeah the following week
I want you to write a letter dear
Mom let me tell you about my life
now I don't want you to describe how
amazing your husband is what he brings
to you how he makes you feel stable
whole loved and seen
I want you to tell your mom about your
new
baby how amazing the birth process was
that she probably did she miss it yeah
yeah that you missed was
amazing and here's what this letter is
it is
Mom here's the daughter you raised
here's what you're going to miss and I'm
going to miss you this is the Heartbreak
letter but it's a truth-telling
letter okay yeah and as we roll into
Christmas this is number four and this
is the hard one and you're like the
other three kind of
suck this is number four it's hard
because it's it's into the
future I want you to write a letter to
your new
baby and I want you to read that letter
I want you to record yourself reading
that letter to your
baby dear
sweetheart you've brought me
light and when you tell that baby what
their life is going to be like how
they're going to be loved how they're
going to be seen and when Mom's not well
which you're going to have seasons when
you're not well too that you're going to
go get help I want you to make
commitments I want you to talk to that
baby through that letter and I want
there to be a recording of it yeah okay
and I think that could be a magical
Christmas gift for a what will be almost
six-month old
yep is that cool okay absolutely and I
want you to look around in the room on
Christmas morning and your mom won't be
there and it's okay to
weep yeah it's okay to be really sad
and like that third letter it's okay to
be like man this is what we got this is
our picture we're going to paint
it we thought we were painting
Landscapes well we're painting dinosaurs
now right yeah if you want to be a real
gangster when you write these letters I
want you to read them out loud to your
husband maybe a couple of your
girlfriends I want you to read it out
loud
okay as the great David Kessler says I
say this all the time grief Demands a
witness y bringing somebody else in and
just reading it out loud there probably
is some stories your husband has no idea
that you experienced is that
fair
yeah you probably have three or four
close girlfriends that love you up
upwards and downwards and sideways and
backwards and forwards and they don't
know what you've been through yeah
yeah so tell them hey Tuesday we're
going for coffee I had to write this
letter because there's more on this
YouTube show told me to do this and I
got to read it to you and it's tough and
so y'all bring grown-up drinks and we're
gonna do this yeah right okay um and
expect to have both things on Christmas
morning
relief
peace and
grief
heartbreak mom should be there Grandma
should be there for babies first and
she's not and thank God she didn't bring
that
chaos
here if you are struggling with
addiction and you happen to be listening
to the show whether it's pornography
whether
it's pills whether it's whatever what's
alcohol
gambling give yourself the gift of
Freedom this Christmas and call somebody
please you're worth so much more and as
you've heard from
Justine you can't get clean for for
other people you can only get clean for
yourself but man your people in your
life that you love and who love you they
deserve that
too make a call Justine you're awesome
anytime I can help holler at me I'd love
to hear how this process goes call me
after Christmas and let me
know both and proud of
you